today on our show we could talk about
iron fist I said you know the iron fist
right where's the wire fist on federal
ban on once's hello a welcome back to a
second it's me mark Barnard and by
myself because Kevin still AWOL do an
awesome [ __ ] as keV is known to do so
today you get once again another solo
mark show and today we're going to talk
about iron fist which drops tomorrow as
I record this on Thursday it will drop
tomorrow on the Netflix on March 17th
effectively in my math works right
because numbers and dates are not my
thing
iron fist which we've talked about
before in a couple of different fashions
trailers drop castings whatever and in
this discussion by iron fist I'm going
to put aside the issue of the casting of
Finn Jones as relates to the racial
identity of Danny Rand in this iteration
we've litigated in the past the idea of
an asian-american or a biracial iron
fist and what that code could not do for
the guy on a story so I'm going to put
that aside we're going to deal with the
show as it stands as it is and I'm not I
could bury the lead a bit and start
talking for a while and get into all of
the reasons why I feel the way I feel
which I will do and then sort of hide
the ball on my feelings towards it I
will say this it is not good it is a
bucket if not good it is a it is a never
ending pasta bowl at Olive Garden of not
good the problem we're going to talk
about the show in three distinct pillars
the first pillar is going to be story
the second pillar is gonna be
performance and the third pillar should
be martial arts because that is a
fundamental part of what a show like
this needs to do so the story of Iron
Fist as related in this TV show that's
executive crews by Scott Bach starring
Tim Jones just good public I think
and David Meacham no David Wenham
playing papa Meacham it'll all make
sense at some point story is Danny ran
thought died in a car crash in a plane
crash with his parents over the winds
and the hills and mountains of the
Himalayas has returned to New York after
being gone for 15 years he wants to
reclaim his place as the rightful heir
of his father's RAND Corporation and he
finds himself back in New York everybody
thinks he's been dead tries to to insist
upon the people who used to be in his
life his quote unquote best friends joy
and Ward Meacham whose father
established the RAND Corporation with
with Benny ranch dad they of course
don't believe that he's actually Daniel
man because why would they believe youth
anyway and describe the fact that I keep
saying these damn UN despite the fact
that we the audience know it anyway they
keep playing as if it's an open question
whether or not he is or isn't who he
says he is he's insisting it's an ear
and they finally accept that he might be
genuine and after they commit him to a
sort of mental institution after they
attempted to kill him when he continues
to insist eats an ear and after he pads
the length of New York with no shoes on
after he meets Colleen wing who's divi
sensei of a dojo in village in New York
and she doesn't believe he's Danny man
but also doesn't give a [ __ ] because
what does she need Danny ran for Danny
ran perceives - - kung fu splain martial
arts - culling wing which whatever and
eventually he's accepted he takes his
place in RAND Corporation only to learn
that the hand who we've been introduced
to in daredevil has taken an active
interest and might have infiltrated
Hydra style the RAND Corporation and as
the iron fist be mortal I insist
the guardian of Conlan it is Danny Rand
sole purpose in life to smash the hand
wherever he finds it that's the story
those of is that that's kind of what
they're trying to the narrative we're
being told
I'm not going to get too spoilery
because again you will see it for
yourself and I in fact have only seen
the first six episodes as we tape I'll
watch the rest when they drop and when
Kevin is back we will talk about it in
its entirety but the story spends way
too much time in the is this Danny Rand
or not Danny ran despite the fact that
we the audience are four episodes of
head of the show in that we know is
Danny man let's get there but the
cardinal sin to me of any television
show is if it's boring and unfortunately
hysterically mysteriously iron fist on
Netflix is boring how you would think
the story of a martial artist back in
New York ready to smash the hand could
be boring if you might have thought how
could they possibly do this they found a
way they found a way it spends like I
said way too much time in an open
question it spends a lot of time in
boardroom scenes with Danny ran not
present and we're supposed to care what
happens in boardrooms at the RAND
Corporation when our heroes not there it
spends lots of time with Danny Rand
sneaking up on people trying to explain
that he's Danny Rand
I'm not offering any actual workable
evidence to his identity even though
again the viewer knows he is it seems as
if he goes about whatever he wants in
the worst way possible and it's also a
question that the show never actually
resolved why Danny Rand came back to New
York again only seen six episodes hoping
they'd sell this or answer this question
in the in the back seven but I don't
know why Danny Wayne is back in New York
I don't know why Danny Rand wants to be
at the head of the red corporation why
not just either stay in : or go back to
the world and walk the world like kung
fu why not fight crime in New York as
eventually he will do but he is
hell-bent on being the head of the RAND
Corporation for reasons that the show
never makes clear and if I don't know
what my hero wants and I don't
understand what the obstacles to him
getting it are then I have a problem
investing and what happens in the show
that at its core
is sort of a cardinal sin of this
iteration of iron fist so let's move on
to performance in Jones is a handsome
enough guy he does blond very well but
there is no depth to the performance
he's giving us there is no sense of an
internal debate for any reason there's
no sense of an internal drive in any
reason there are scenes where he tries
to the show presents him somehow as both
serene and petty at the same time where
he will talk about you know the divine
wisdom of the seven temples or he will
offer some Buddhist aphorism or he will
talk about you know the key to martial
artists to find your inner spirit and to
calm the demons within all while being
incredibly petty about things like you
know lawsuits and corporate machinery
and you know why don't you believe me I
am I am who I say I am like there's and
those two things don't mesh well
together it's as if they're expecting us
to by sort of hollow
as holy and that doesn't come across in
the show there are just moments where I
mean he's the humor such as it is that's
supposed to happen in the show doesn't
come across the the fish-out-of-water
mists of it all doesn't really come
across as such you just left with a bit
of a vacuum at the center of the show
and we've talked before about the the
genius that Marvel has had in the
casting for their Netflix shows how
great it was the cat how the casting of
the Punisher is fantastic
how my cultures Luke Cage is really
strong how Vincent d'Onofrio's the
kingpin is a masterstroke how all of
those shows have a texture and the
deafness to both reinterpreting and
presenting these Marvel characters in
ways that are both surprising and
familiar which is a nifty
to have to do but it feels like here too
much of it feels too on-the-nose like
the guy was playing warden Meechum who
absolutely hates Danny R and the minute
he shows up just feels like a sort of
mustache twirling trust-fund baby where
his father played by David Wenham from
Laura the ring just feels ambiently evil
without any actual direction towards it
so you don't know how to feel about him
you know like I have my issues with the
the Luke aid show feel like it's it
tries to do much more than it actually
does but that the effort is part of what
makes it worthwhile but where they
excelled was the casting of everybody
around my culture like marshal Ali alfre
woodard the entire cast that worked in
that show to envelop my culture is
fantastic that such thing doesn't exist
here with the exception of you get
rosario Dawson again as Claire temple
you you get carrie anne moss
again as you know lawyer trinity and
then the actress playing colleague wing
is actually pretty smart and strong even
though the character is woefully
underwritten and so her only mode is
sort of grim and detached as opposed to
ever engaging with the mystery that
we're supposed to think is danny man so
without sort of story to work for you in
the show without characters to work for
you in the show you would hope that when
you show up to an iron fist show you
would get a level of martial arts that
would blow your mind um you don't you
don't and the martial arts we get are
like fine for TV in 2002 you know like
if this was this is a you know Steven JK
me I'll show you going oh this is
[ __ ] awesome look what they're
pulling off here we got cage matches and
we got street fights and we got hallway
duels but the fact that we've seen all
of that stuff done before so much better
the fact that the hallway fight in
daredevil is great despite the fact that
the prison fight in daredevil season two
is great despite the fact that
Luque dripping a card or often barging
into a tenement building is great
despite the fact that into the badlands
manages every week to do amazing legit
martial arts does not help doesn't have
Iron Fist the fact that John wick exists
in any iteration does not help because
the thing that makes martial arts work
on screen is time it's time and focus
and intention and you need the time to
train your app is so that they can
pretend to look like they're doing
martial arts I don't ever want to see a
cutaway to a stuntman and you can count
the stuntmen in on it fish you can Carol
yeah after him fast on him after doing
the blonde wig and you can see it you
can see what it happened and that's the
problem I mean martial arts when it
sells when it's convincing it is you
lock a camera down you show me the
martial art you cut and when you cut it
for emotional effect is to show me
somebody getting hit for real is to show
me your character making the choice is
to show me the repercussions of the
actions on screen as opposed to hiding
the action but your actors can't pull
off and it buries to a certain degree in
the show I mean the actors who plays
calling wing is actually pretty good at
it even though the camera doesn't trust
her to be good at it but you can tell
she has some skill at this but the you
don't have the excuse anymore like take
the time take your actors train them for
a couple of months is what they do it
into the badlands you put them in a
warehouse for eight weeks and you teach
them every fight until they know it
until they know it blindfolded but they
know it so that we can buy it I don't
need to I don't need to know I don't
need to feel that Finn Jones is an
actual martial artist I need to feel
that he's a decent enough mimic I need
to feel that he can do the dance because
this is dance ultimately and I don't
feel it not for a second not for a
second
and he never sells the like I'm just
going to do [ __ ] Taichi here and sent
to myself he never sells me I'm angry
because the name comes off as petulant
you never sells me I'm resolved because
resolve comes off as distracted and all
of that plays into the martial arts of
the show and the martial arts is where
this has to sing especially if nothing
else does you know like I've been going
back and watching lots of old Star Trek
lots of old Twilight Zone
shows where you can absolutely tell that
the special effects are not what they
should be the thing that that the
whiz-bang of the show doesn't function
but if the story is strong enough you
don't care and if the story can't be
strong enough
the whiz-bang has to be busy and banging
and if none of those work I have to give
a [ __ ] about what happens for the
characters in the middle of it
it's a Trinity of the way genre TV has
to work and in this instance there's no
legs of these tripods that are holding
up the weight of iron fist which is a
shame because there's so much
opportunity on the table for a good eye
on this show it's a shame
maybe a necessary shame that Marvel had
their first real ding you know that that
even though I have my issues with with
agents of shield it's a network show it
operates on those rules and they've
actually found their way to telling
pretty good stories but this is the
fourth time that folks has done this and
the first three are pretty good the fact
that they just I don't know like
absent-mindedness you know lack of
intention lack of trust for the source
material and a lack of a desire to trust
themselves to alter the source material
as just sort of resulted in a show that
is not much of anything besides there's
colors on screen that are doing things
there's people who might be punching you
know like I don't want their iron fist
to be losing fights that's not what
that's about you know like I get it but
there's got to be some upward trajectory
for him there needs to be boss fights
where he gets you know hurt and when
he's got a power to the pain what every
fight shouldn't be a boss fight half the
time I should just be watching Monica's
people you know and I remember this
conversation with a friend about Pacific
Rim where if [ __ ] danger has a [ __ ]
laser sword why doesn't the first thing
that happens is [ __ ] danger pops a
laser sword why not if that's the weapon
to end all weapons you have to come up
with a decent story reason for it to be
a thing that gets deployed at the very
tail end besides we had a cool thing to
happen I don't know why in this show
you know juicy iron fists all the time
why would you withhold the iron fist
does it cost him something TV at this
does it expect does he spend energy that
he can use any more to iron fists out if
not that everything should be a non
infant open a [ __ ] can of soda iron
fist
crack an egg I insist brush your teeth I
don't fit because why wouldn't you if
every the solution to her problem is
answers then every problem should be
[ __ ] simple but because they don't
come up with that reason I just keep
waiting for Iron Fist and every time he
doesn't use it I don't care
in summary I insisted a bit of a mess
and maybe it's an instructive miss maybe
it's maybe it's the the the knock to the
applecart that sets it right again maybe
it it's the realization that you can't
actually do this on autopilot that maybe
you actually need to give real thoughts
to every decision you're making on
screen because this show feels as if
every time they were faced with a
decision they made the wrong one and
it's not the wrong one the lazy one and
TV is hard it's supposed to be hard it's
supposed to being rigorous you're
supposed to rattle test every decision
you make every every move you put on
screen every script choice every
narrative call you make should be
checked and rechecked and shake it out
and put through the ringer and like fire
in a crucible to make sure that there's
no other way you could have gone or that
you made a gut check because this stuff
like the right way and if this is the
case then somebody felt the wrong way
about these things and went with it
anyway I say all of this saying that
maybe the back seven are fantastic the
last of the six that I saw the last two
were better than the first four so maybe
there's a trajectory towards great but
this is pulp storytelling this is this
is comic book storytelling even if
you're executing it to the venous of its
level it is still pump pump should move
pulp should pump should be breathless
you know like we live in a for better or
worse and whether you've seen them or
not we live in a post shonda rhimes
universe we live we live in the universe
where I should feel
the wind of story in my hair every
[ __ ] time
and we shouldn't slow down why slow now
would you get for Sona what do you what
do you benefit by taking a pause to have
a character hold a meeting about
anything meetings have no place unless
the meeting is how do we destroy
Galactus all right perturbation meaning
all right how do we how do we stop a
portal from opening up into storing
Manhattan all right maybe we stand
around the adventure table and have a
couple of thoughts but if the meeting is
about you know I don't know should we
release this drug this minute medicine
for the market not supernatural not
nefarious but just like a medicine to
the market at Koster should be ranking
up by 200% because the word the ran
company really wants the profits but
Danny Rand believes that that kind of
profit is sort of unholy and not in line
with his disbelief
no dear [ __ ] don't need don't want
boardroom scenes don't want any of that
[ __ ] I don't I don't need to see Danny
Rand ever talk to a secretary and you
don't I need to feed be honest response
from people to walls if you give me more
of that we're good we're good
and like I said back seven could be
phenomenal I shouldn't have to wait six
episodes to get to phenomenal
you should just deliver phenomenal unto
me and it's also show that occasionally
forgets that we've seen three other
Marvel shows so the mystery of what's
the hand is not a mystery I give a [ __ ]
about because I know what the hand is
you know what the hand is Claire temple
knows what the hand is in fact she knows
what the hand is more than anybody else
in the show why why like don't don't
make the characters have to play catch
up the stuff that I already know and
have known for years at this point let's
advance the story let's continue it
let's push forward let's let's assume
that you and I and everybody who's
tuning in to watch Netflix the day it
drops knows what the handi what's the
next beat of that story how does the
hand in Pat Danny Rams life how does it
how does it complicate his relationships
with people how does it prevent him from
being the audience's that's a story that
I want to start with not eventually want
to get to
you know hey maybe maybe this is all
just necessary in their mind maybe in
order for us to get to the defenders of
course Danny Rand needs to be challenged
needs to be broken so he can be put back
together again but that shouldn't be
this sluggish that shouldn't be this
Hollow they should be way more evolving
way more involving you know like the
defenders shouldn't have to exist in a
world where it feels like it's
apologizing for the iron fist TV show
and if the last seven are in any way
reflective of the first six defenders is
going to have to earn a little bit back
from us as viewers and then it's not a
place you want to be in so hey you watch
on fist tell me I'm wrong tell me the
various and sundry ways that I'm wrong
but remember I am not in any way saying
that the reasons why this show doesn't
work is because Danny Rand is an Asian
or because Danny Rand isn't biracial
even though I do in my heart of hearts
think that's a better show you get more
drama you have more places to go you get
different stories that I haven't seen
before if you do that and you still get
to retain all the things that McDaniel
ran great I am saying that the show as
written if you had put a better white
guy in there it would have been more
interesting if you had even this average
white guy do better stuff it would have
been interesting even if you had this
average white guy in a piss-poor story
but you spent eight months doing the
martial arts that would have been better
but as such it just sits there and
television in this day and age can't
afford to just sit there right I said
when Kevin back hopefully next week we
will talk about a lot of things we will
talk about iron fist again once you've
seen all of it let's talk about Logan
we'll talk about The Matrix is getting
rebooted again huh we will done we will
people cover all of the awesome we will
get down deep but for now it is just me
talking about iron fist lamenting the
lack of iron fist analysis so that's it
for our show
come on back next week same bat-time
same bat-channel youtube.com
silversmiths Shemin smith
Kevin Smith or SModcast calm I have been
märklin Arden I hope you enjoyed our
tour into the horrors of the Iron Fist
television show baby that's too strong
it's not horrible it is just boring and
honestly I would have rather it was
horrible because horrible is exciting
bad the right kind of bad has a sizzle
to it a lot of sizzle happening here I'm
not a lot of steak either like tofu a
kind of tofu you might eat including on
aha run it back around see you next week
guys
[Music]